what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
this morning we just got
the official teaser trailer for the
eternals this is a lot more than the
sneak peak trailer that we got not too
long ago this is a full teaser trailer
it is two minutes
and seven seconds long it was amazing
visually this movie is going to be
absolutely
insane and there is a lot in this teaser
trailer to break down
so let's get started but first reminder
only seven days left in my stormbreaker
giveaway all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel
and cosmic culture to enter this first
scene that we open up on
is of an ancient village these people
look like they might have just
invented the wheel their civilization
isn't that far along and that kind of
shows when the eternals show up because
remember the eternals are essentially
immortal they've been alive for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years
the eternals were actually created by
the celestial
gods in the marvel comics the celestials
actually experimented on the early
humans so the first humans that were
made the celestials took some of them
experimented on them and created the
eternals from there on out they tasked
the eternals with
guarding and protecting earth and the
people of earth
and this scene is apparently when the
eternals first get to earth as we can
see their ship here
and we can see the people absolutely
shocked to see a
huge ship that is invisible come right
in front of them the first eternals that
we see
on the ship are icarus and cersei icarus
is looking at the window kind of
marveling at earth pun intended and
sarsi comes up and says
it's beautiful isn't it further implying
that this probably is the first time
that the eternals are arriving on earth
fun fact cersei is played by jimmy chan
jimmy chan was also
in the movie captain marvel she played
the role of
minn irva marvel thought that she was so
great that she got the main role of
cersei for the
eternals now from here we see a few
other eternals and get a glimpse inside
their ship we see salma hayek's
character ajax walking down the hall and
she is the leader of the eternals it
looks like she walks into a room and in
that room we get
our first look at angelina jolie's thena
and she looks absolutely insane
fina is the warrior the fighter of the
group which is very suiting for angelina
jolie
now in this room that the eternals are
in we can see several different things
we get a close-up of salma hayek's
character and her outfit
and behind her it looks like there could
be some plants in the background perhaps
these plants they actually put on earth
to help the humans kind of start growing
trees and vegetation
although they do kind of look alien-like
so perhaps they could be something from
wherever the celestials created them we
then see
two new characters brian tyree henry's
fastos and liam mchugh's sprite
now in this scene we see fastos kind of
manipulating something
fastos is the eternals is master
technologist and although we don't
really know what this
is it probably is some type of a tool or
technology that he's using for something
that i'm sure we'll figure out within
the first
two minutes of the movie also sitting
behind him is sprite
sprite is kind of the playful trickster
of the group and can cast
illusions and spread is actually an
adult but stuck
in the body of a child and although the
mcu doesn't ever completely just do what
the comics did we can assume that all of
the eternals were indeed made at the
same time
then we cut to the marvel studios logo
and the first thing that we see
is cersei with the humans on earth
farming she's helping them and then we
hear the voice of salma hayek's ajax
saying
we have watched and guided we have
helped them progress and as she says
this we can actually see one of the
eternal's
hands create water on the ground from
here
vegetation grows so again the eternals
were created to
protect and guide the humans and it
looks like that's exactly what they're
doing from the very beginning and we can
kind of see the humans progress
as sama hayek is talking now the
eternals basically help the very first
civilization evolve and we see that they
go from a civilization that is kind of
just sitting on the rocks pitching tents
to a civilization that has its very own
city with a large wall around it and
this is pretty much
mesopotamia or since they said they've
helped them accomplish wonders it could
be one of the wonders of the world
i wouldn't be surprised if marvel kind
of worked that in there it would be
pretty clever
and as you can see in this one scene all
of the humans seem to be
kneeling to them like they're gods so
there's going to be a lot of mythology
from real life put into this movie
and it looks like they're going to make
it to where some of the old ancient
egyptian gods and hieroglyphics that
we've seen
are actually the eternals in the mcu
since they are the ones that came from
space
and a huge giant ship and then helped
them now in one scene we see one eternal
handing
a very particular looking knife to
somebody else this is most likely ajac
and i don't think she's giving the knife
to another person i think she is showing
a human the knife i think she's kind of
showing them
who they are and i'm sure this knife is
going to have a pretty significant
purpose and there was a leak that talked
about there was a tool that ajac has
that helps her communicate with the
celestials this could be it
but right now we're not that certain we
also get a scene where athena is
seemingly training
warriors remember she's the warrior and
the fighter of the group
now if you take a look at her spear that
she is fighting with it looks like it's
actually made out of some type of energy
it's transparent it doesn't look like
it's made out of something like solid
gold but one of the powers of
the majority of the eternals is energy
manipulation this is much like we saw
fastas doing in the very beginning of
the teaser trailer dina also wears some
sort of a crown on her head that has a
symbol on it that i'm sure will be
revealed to us during the movie and if
you look at her face she doesn't seem to
be that happy she actually seems to be
rather sad or concerned
athena is apparently going to have a
pretty big secret
in this movie according to recent rumors
most likely the fact that she actually
has
a child in the comics actually twins
however she gives the children away to
an actual human and she keeps them a
secret and this could be her big secret
here and this could be what she's upset
about she could be pregnant or she could
have
already given up the kids now as we
continue on salma hayek's character says
throughout the years we have never
interfered and here we get a few more
scenes
one is of lauren ridloff's character
makari she is
reading and she is reading very very
fast because that is one of her specific
abilities she is very
very fast she'd give the flash a run for
his money
and as you can see she is actually on
the ship this is actually from
the same scene we got in the very
beginning and it looks like she has
collected just a bunch of stuff from
humanity over time from different
civilizations so it kind of looks like
she's living on the ship
we have everything from ancient statues
of the egyptian periods to
new lamps that actually have light bulbs
in them so this shows you their
immortality they can live for thousands
and thousands of years
and it looks like for makari at least
her goal is to learn as much as she can
even though she was a part of it all
perhaps she could be searching for
something and she has to search through
the history of the people to find out
now as selma hayek says we have never
interfered we see sarzi walking through
what i'm going to call mesopotamia and
then we see her in modern times
living amongst the people in normal
clothes now this is what cersei does
this is who she is she actually loves
people she loves humanity and she
prefers to live with the people instead
of the eternals
now samahayek says we've never
interfered even though they basically
built an established civilization and
everything is pretty much a result of
them helping but we see humanity start
to kind of go at war with each other and
this is where the eternals don't
interfere it looks like they kind of
started them off and then let them go so
we kind of start to see wars here
villages being ramsacked and the
eternals basically just sit back and
watch
however then we hear ajax say until
now and there are a few very important
scenes that we have to talk about the
first one
is of gilgamesh and another eternal
holding hands
now the eternals holding hands is nice
but that's not what we're looking at
here we're actually looking at what is
happening
in the background in the background it
looks like we actually see
some sort of a figure this looks like it
could be a hologram or a projection
of one of the celestials after all we do
know that the eternals do have to
communicate with the celestials
sometimes
however in another scene in the village
where some of the eternals seemingly
live
we can see one of the eternals fighting
something it looks like it's some type
of a horse because it has four legs but
it looks like it's
definitely not anything of earth now it
could be
a deviant the deviants are essentially
relatives of the eternals
when the celestials created the eternals
they also created what is known as the
deviance the eternals are basically a
perfected experiment and the deviants
are kind of where it went wrong
and in the comics they're basically at
war with each other from the very
beginning
thanos is actually a deviant himself
thanos was born
of two eternal parents however he
inherited the deviant gene which is why
he looks all purple and weird
and who knows perhaps thanos is actually
the son of theena that would be a pretty
cool twist for them to throw in there
and perhaps that's why the eternals are
finally getting involved thanos is
threatening to kill not only half the
people on earth but half the people in
the universe
it could be that or could be other
deviant threats as well now something
else to note about this scene
is that somebody is apparently mind
controlling some of the villagers
we can see all of them pull guns out at
the same time and we can see all of
their eyes are glowing
so somebody is definitely controlling
them the question
is who it could be one of the eternals
we don't know all of their powers since
the mcu will most likely change what
their powers are
or it could be the villain now another
awesome scene
that we see is with cersei druid and
makari
they are all levitating off of the
ground and there's energy going into
them
and in between them now what they're
most likely doing here
is forming the uni mind the uni mind is
created when several eternals come
together and
join their will and intelligence they
come together and create
one giant being created of light mind
and pure
energy this is going to be absolutely
crazy to see on scene
and it looks like they're probably doing
this right before they have to fight the
big bad villain at the end of the movie
and then we get a few scenes of icarus
and
cersei they definitely have some romance
going on here looks like they start out
as a couple and then they
end up eventually getting married as we
can see here it definitely looks like a
wedding ceremony and it looks like
they're together for a pretty long time
however it does look like we're going to
have a love triangle here because we
know that cersei is also going to be
involved with dane whitman
aka the black knight played by kit
harrington and we actually do have a
scene here with sarzi
and kit harrington it definitely looks
like more modern time so
maybe her and icarus end up breaking up
or who knows
then we get a pretty awesome scene of
camille nanjiani's character who is
a bollywood star he is living among the
humans and sort of hiding in plain sight
and he's clearly made a pretty good life
for himself kamel nanjiani actually
talked about a huge bollywood dance
scene that they did and it looks like
they show us some of that in this
trailer
and then of course we get the awesome
scene on the cliffside
where we see all of the eternals fully
dressed in their eternals
outfits from the left to the right we
have camille nanjiani's character kingo
lauren ridloff's character makari ma
dong socks character gilgamesh
angelina jolie astina richard madden as
icarus salma hayek as
ajak jima chan as cersei leah mchugh as
sprite
brian tyree henry as fastos and barry
keegan as
druid and those are the eternals now we
have one more scene left that
kind of answers a question to an extent
that a lot of people have been having
which is where exactly were the eternals
during
the events of thanos we have what looks
like most of the eternals sitting down
at a table with a
very nice spread that looks like it was
provided by gilgamesh icarus looks up at
gilgamesh and says thank you for this
and he says you're welcome and then
sprite poses a question to the eternals
and that question is so now that captain
rogers and
iron man are both gone who do you think
is going to lead the avengers so they
definitely know who the avengers are
so it does seem like they were
monitoring everything but why didn't
they interfere
was there some other threat that they
had to deal with at this point in time
we are definitely going to get the
answer to that in this movie
however it does look like some of the
eternals if not probably most of it
takes place after the snap
the reason being is because in this
scene kingo who was the famous bollywood
star
has a character with him who is not an
eternal we saw this character in the
teaser trailer holding a camera so it's
either his cameraman
and or assistant this means that this
scene at the end where sprite asks about
the avengers
takes place before the eternals are kind
of coming back together and reforming
their group to take on whatever threat
is threatening them
so their major threat the one that ajax
was saying we've never interfered until
now
is happening after captain america and
iron man are gone which means it's
happening
after the snap and then of course the
final scene is of icarus saying
i could lead them i could lead the
avengers angelina jolie
kind of rolls her eyes and everybody
starts to laugh
and that's the eternals trailer and
marvel is really treating us with their
teaser trailers their teasers are pretty
long over two minutes
and they packed so much into this teaser
trailer it was awesome but let me know
what you thought about it in the
comments down below and let me know if
you have any questions about it as well
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all things related to
the eternals and the mcu
don't forget to hit that like button and
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof